MODERATOR: We'd like to welcome
Chris Elliott, solutions
architect, to talk
about Google Cloud.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Thanks.
Glad to be here.
So, fun story, when you
get really close to time,
there's an entire Google posse
that stands up in the corner
and starts going like
this and walking closer.
So that's a great counter.
So we're going to talk
about Google Cloud Platform
and how you can build games that
are scalable and will really
be able to handle the
load when you launch.
So my name is Chris Elliott.
I always like to start
with a terrible picture.
And this one is actually
one of my favorites,
because it's in publications
that are commonly
found in restrooms
all over the world.
So on my resume
literally is a bullet
that says "found on toilets
all over the world."
And it's a terrible photo.
But as an architect, I work
and help tidy up the platform
to solve a lot of the
real world use cases
that people are tackling--
game developers specifically.
So about that, basically
four sections here broken
down into-- first just an
overview of the platform,
make sure we're all on the
exact same page in terms
of the core fundamental
building blocks there.
And then really the
meat and potatoes
of diving into some example,
real world implementation
the developers have
built, and also
talk about in an ideal
world, what you could build.
So you can mix and
match and choose
what works best for
your use case here.
So when looking at the
Google Cloud Platform,
we provide a variety of compute
platforms, storage services,
and additional services
to layer on top of that.
And really, it's a
little bit confusing,
because there are a
lot of moving parts.
And you're not
quite sure which one
is the best one to
use for your use case.
And so I hope by the
end of this session,
everyone here will understand
some potential ways
of combining these
technologies to solve
the really challenging
problems we face.
And rest assured,
you're not alone.
We have a lot of customers
who are very happy in the game
industry building
on our platform.
And it's amazing,
because usually you
see a couple developers
build something on it that
scales and goes
and doesn't crash.
Everyone kind of
picks up on that,
and you see Google Cloud
Platform adoption just growing
within companies.
And here are a
couple of examples.
And you'll notice it goes
everywhere from small indie
studios all the way up
to AAA game studios.
We see everyone across
the board benefiting
from the value and
power of the platform.
And a couple examples, for
example, Electronic Arts,
initially started with
just one mobile title.
But its scaled-- it didn't
go down, it didn't crash.
It was a small dev team.
It was ideal, and it made
everyone else envious
who was hammering away and
managing our infrastructure.
And then now they're
using it for a lot
of their mobile applications
that they're building out,
and you may recognize
a few from here.
Another one-- actually.
I found this out last GDC when
just talking to Epic Games--
that they actually used App
Engine for "Infinity Blade II,"
and the compelling
social features there.
It was really cool
too, because it
was done by just one
guy in about six weeks.
And that is a really
compelling note,
because if I was a developer
and I had six weeks to build
something I knew
millions of people
were going to be
hammering, I would
be on the edge of my seat.
And luckily, it scaled
up, and it handled.
And it just worked.
And it's just another one
of those example use cases
where people are
really harnessing
the power of the
platform and using
the right tool
for the right job.
And so to look at a few of
the few building blocks,
really when building on
the Google Cloud platform,
the two things you
have to choose about
are whether you want to use
Compute Engine, App Engine, how
do I mix and match,
and really what
is the best tool
for my use case.
So we'll start with Compute
Engine, which there's
been a lot of excitement
around recently since we
went GA in December.
And with that, the core way
to describe the platform
is it's virtual machines--
open and flexible
virtual machines that you can
bring whatever software stack
you want, and run that
on a Linux machine
and be good to go.
And so bring your
dedicated game servers,
anything that you want that
doesn't quite necessarily fit
within the App Engine
containerized environment.
It's a great fit
on Compute Engine.
And the next couple
of slides, there
are really two
points that I've seen
be very compelling
for game developers.
The first one is
the global network
and the performance
of the network
opens up new
opportunities with respect
to cloud gaming, and also
the consistent performance.
Not only is it a very
high performance system,
every machine performs
at a high level,
so you can design depending
on those consistent benchmarks
in the back end.
And so with that,
the first network--
the first point is really the
network that spans the globe.
We have our own
private fiber network,
and Compute Engine
taps into that.
It's built on
Google data centers.
And it really allows
you to do things
that you can't and have
never been able to do before
on previous cloud platforms,
just because you're
running over Google's
private fiber.
One of the fun parts
about being inside Google
is you get to see
behind the scenes.
There's a really classic
video of inspecting
one of our transatlantic
fiber lines.
And out of nowhere,
a shark comes out,
bites onto the cable.
And luckily, the cable
is wrapped in Kevlar
and designed to
withstand shark attacks.
And it's really
cool to actually be
able to go and see shark
attacks happening and knowing
that your app's
still going to go.
Although the fiber can withstand
that, if I was developer
and I had a small little
outage for 1% and it was due
a shark attack, I would actually
be much more comfortable
than, say, a go-to
fail statement issue.
I would much rather have
a shark attack happening.
But anyways, we get a
lot of press on platform.
And people are really picking
up on what we're doing.
This one quote in "Wired"
I absolutely love,
because it summarize
everything we're doing,
and how we're exposing
Google's history
and experience
with infrastructure
to external developers to get
in and harness that power.
And it really sums up as
the mother of all clouds.
And yes, our data centers
really do look like that.
There are some really
great pictures there.
In one of them, you might
have seen the Easter egg
with a stormtrooper in it.
And I'm pretty sure that
exists there as well.
But people are noticing this.
I worked with Ed
over at PA Consulting
on a bunch of
Chrome Jam projects.
One of them was-- actually,
one was called Chrome Jam.
And these are projects
by the Chrome team.
And this one was
basically required
very low latency
connections so they
could stream audio
between four clients,
and friends could just jam on,
log in, choose an instrument,
and just start jamming
with each other.
And this quote was
straight from them.
They absolutely love the
latency that they were seeing.
It was low, much lower than they
were designing for elsewhere.
And it actually allowed
them to launch successfully
instead of having to scrap the
project because of latency.
What does that actually
mean in numbers?
Well, here's a study that,
although it's over a year old,
these numbers just get
even better and better
from this point on.
And the coloring is
accidental of other,
but it's fairly accurate per se.
But this is between two
regions, and what you can see--
and the really key thing
is trying to highlight,
as game developers, what
are the key metrics?
Latency-- we're looking at
significantly lower latency
that enables you to do
things that you haven't been
able to do before across
regional deployments,
and also bandwidth.
Every instance
within Compute Engine
exists on a project
private network
and can communicate over
an internal network.
So you can literally
create an instance in EU,
create an instance in US, and
say, ping my European instance.
And that's all over
internal private network.
Of course, you have to have
firewall ports open and all
that, and we walk
you through that.
But it's one of the
powerful features.
And even instance creation--
although it doesn't necessarily
involve having a
faster-performing instance,
the fact you can create an
instance and go to SSH into it,
and it's almost always there,
that is very compelling.
I'm no longer just sitting
around waiting for my instances
to be created.
And it's great when you're
spinning up 1,000 instances
to meet with an unexpected
surge in demand.
And one last benchmark,
just to kind of give you
a sense and validate what we're
talking about here in terms
of performance, is this
MapR terasort record.
And there are two reasons I
really love this for gaming.
One is the previous
record was held
on dedicated hardware in
their own data center.
And we smashed
that record sorting
a terabyte of data on a
cloud-based deployment.
Nobody would have
expected cloud performance
to exceed that of what they
had on dedicated hardware.
And you'll see that we used a
third of the number of cores.
And the other aspect is-- and
the reason this was possible--
is because of that
consistent performance.
You don't have a couple
of MapReduce nodes hanging
around being slow, dragging
the entire job back down.
Everything spins up quickly,
computes, shuts down.
And that's why they're
able to smash that record.
And for gaming, it's important.
If you have 2%, 3%, 5% of
your servers not performing
correctly, you're going to have
5% of your user base having
a bad experience.
And this is one of the ways we
can help avoid that problem.
So the other aspect-- and I'm
not spending a lot of time
on it in this overview, because
a lot of people I talk to
are already intimately
familiar with App Engine
and understand what it provides.
They may love it,
or they may have not
used it for other
reasons, such as wanting
to run their own dedicated
game server that doesn't work
within the App Engine container.
But I absolutely
love App Engine.
It scales to
unbelievable heights.
The developers I've worked
with that have built on it
have been doing amazing things
with extremely small teams--
easy to build, easy to scale.
And if you're running in
PHP, Go, Java, or Python,
it's always great to evaluate if
it's a right tool for your job,
or whether you need
to leverage and add
on other things such
as Compute Engine.
So that's really the
high level overview, just
trying to keep it brief.
And I'll be around
afterwards if you
have more questions
about those components.
But really, I wanted to
jump into some things
that people are
actually building,
and what did it look like.
So the first one is "Song Pop."
How many people in
the audience have
played this game,
out of curiosity?
A few hands, so about
80 million users
played this game-- fairly
successful by app standards.
And basically it's
you go in, and you
compete against your friend for
who is the best at song trivia,
do recognize this song, do
you recognize this title,
do you recognize this artist?
And so with that, this is
their daily active users.
And I remember being involved
at about near the very beginning
of that hockey stick, and
hearing about this app
and how it was
growing massively.
And then it just
kept going and going,
up until about 300 million
requests per day-- and this
is all backed by App Engine--
and three billion data
store operations per day.
And the most amazing
thing about this
is there's one back end
developer for this game.
And he actually got to enjoy
his weekends off and sleep
at night.
And they actually
attribute App Engine
to be one of the reasons
why they're successful,
because instead of worrying
about their system scaling,
having to maintain a NoSQL
database that is doing three
billion rows, three
billion operations per day,
instead they're able to focus on
adding the features people are
asking in order to keep
that hockey stick growing.
And they absolutely
love the platform,
and have released their
newest title on it
as well called "Movie Pop"--
which you can probably
guess the spin on that,
but it's also really cool.
And so what does
the architecture
look like behind this?
Well, here's what it looks like.
It's actually pretty
straightforward.
It's efficient, and it gets
the job done, and scales.
And you'll notice I say
scale a lot during this talk,
but scaling really is
the heart of everything
we try and do at Google and
expose to all developers
out there.
And so the key aspect of
this is the core game logic
running on App Engine instances.
They're using Python and
having all those mobile device
syncing into App Engine, have
all the game logic there.
For example, all
the user profiles
are stored in data store.
All their songs,
all their scores,
all the playlists
they've played,
all their friends stored
in the data store.
And so when you have
80 million users,
you need a NoSQL
database that scales up
and can handle that load.
And similarly,
all of their songs
are stored in cloud storage.
So what happens
is you'll request
to play a game with a friend.
They'll get a push notification.
And then you'll both
retrieve that data
from cloud storage of all
the song samples, play,
and then push the results
back into App Engine.
And so it's fairly
straightforward,
but it scales when you
use components right.
And they're designed
for scalability in mind.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about the actual components
here in other
architectures as well.
And another one that
I was lucky enough
to be involved with
at the very beginning
is "Motorola Spotlight Stories."
Out of curiosity,
how many people
have Moto X in the audience?
And how many of you have
played the spotlight stories?
And they're awesome, right?
Yeah, they're
absolutely awesome.
A friend of mine reached
out at Motorola an asked
if I'd be interested in helping
out with some 20% project work.
So I went over and talked
to the team at Motorola,
and I was blown away.
Because behind this door
was this creative team
that worked on so many of
my favorite Pixar movies.
You had Oscar-winning
directors, you
had the animator who animated
Woody in "Toy Story."
Everyone was there
in the room, and I
had no idea what to
expect when I was just
asked to come and
help out with 20%.
Ironically, I had Glass on,
and it was still fairly new.
And so I was both in shock,
and they were both in shock,
and we kind of had a moment.
But they got an amazing creative
team, spent a ton of time
building their own
custom game engine
and hiring amazing animators.
Everything here is
hand-animated frame by frame.
And if you have a Moto X, or
you know a friend with a Moto X,
just ask to borrow it.
I'll always remember
in the office,
we have a lot of
Moto X's at Google.
And everyone there is
just looking around,
interacting in the world.
And it's just an
amazing experience
and really cool stuff they did.
But what does it
actually look like?
Well, here's the
core architecture.
So on the Moto X itself, they
wrote their own native engine,
OpenGL 3.0.
Some really great stuff
there to power the in-game,
and it runs on
Android 4.4 Kit Kat.
What's interesting there
is the actual Java services
they've implemented.
And so all of the story
scripts and art assets
are kept within Cloud Storage.
So what happens is your
device, about once a day,
just checks in with
App Engine, check
and see if there's
any new content
stories, anything at all.
And if there is, it gets that
information from the datastore.
And then App Engine will return
a signed URL to the device
that it can then download all
of those assets to the phone.
And similarly, on the cloud,
you have the Admin panel
for adding new assets,
adding new stories.
And that's the cloud
platform aspect.
And the other interesting
thing they're doing here
is their engine service.
I mean, this is perfectly timed
after the Analytics session.
And so they're using Google
Analytics for everything
to see how users are
playing, how many times are
people playing it.
If you actually play
one of the movies,
like "Windy Day"
or "Buggy Night,"
you can follow along the story
and kind of interact with it.
But if you just
detour off, there's
all these really funny
things you wouldn't even
notice are happening
unless you take your time.
And you can get a sense for
what people are looking at,
what really excites people,
what do they look at a lot.
So that's the
architecture behind that.
And more than willing to
talk about these later on,
and there's lots
of architectures.
But we have 30
minutes, so this is
a whirlwind tour of
everything great in cloud.
So now we're going to talk about
some reference architectures
here.
And these really are,
in an ideal world,
what would the perfect
implementation look
like on Google Cloud platform.
And feel free to mix and
match and choose whatever
is best for your implementation,
because there's no wrong way
to build when you use the
tools you're familiar with
and sprinkle in the
technology that you know
is going to be there for
you when your game grows.
So the first one
we're looking at
is Gaming Reference
Architecture, specifically
with player versus player,
intense multiplaying,
low latency dedicated
game servers.
So the past two we talked
about were more mobile
focused, mobile device focused.
This is what I do when I
get home for five hours
until I can't stay
awake anymore.
And it's really about building
a full-featured gameplay
experience.
So with these reference
architectures,
we like to pack up a
sample application as well,
to show you that it's fairly
straightforward to get
the bare bones
implementation up and running
so you can start
sprinkling in custom logic.
And for that, about two years
ago at Google I/O, we-- Colt,
actually-- developed
this game called "GRITS."
And it was meant to
show HTML5, and having
a whole bunch of
robots running around
on screen shooting each other.
We took that as the
core gameplay element
and sprinkled in the
auto-scaling game cluster
aspect.
So essentially, what you have is
this core fun gameplay mechanic
requiring dedicated servers.
And what we've added to it is a
whole bunch of App Engine logic
for scaling up, scaling
down, maintaining status
of all the clusters, and doing
some of the straightforward
matchmaking logic.
So what does this
actually look like?
Well, I apologize for the big
architecture diagrams to start.
Typically, I like
to reveal these.
But then I feel bad, because
everyone in the audience
takes a picture, and the next
slide, ooh, there's more,
takes a picture.
And about eight slides
later, it's finally revealed.
And so with this one--
and the thing I really
want you to focus on
is down in the bottom,
you'll see Compute
Engine instances
connected to mobile devices.
And that is where the majority
of the gameplay of the player
is going to happen.
It's just directly connecting
to those instances,
running the dedicated
game servers,
handling all those connections.
But as you know,
there's a lot more
that it takes to actually make
a game that players are going
to come back to and
that they're going
to have a great time with.
And that's really
where App Engine comes
in as the brains of
building a game type like,
a game like this.
And Compute Engine
is really the brawn
of just running the
dedicated game servers.
So with respect to
server matchmaking,
Memcache is low latency,
in-memory caching.
And you want to think
about, for example,
keeping a list of
all your servers
and their current
stats in Memcache,
so every single person who
looks for a server can instantly
get that back, and you're not
taking the cost of extra data
center reads with respect to
latency and monetary value
as well.
Another important thing as well
is processing in-game requests.
If players have
custom configuration,
they want to download that
down to the game server.
Or if they want to
purchase things,
or if you want to keep
track of kill/death ratios
at the end of a match.
All of that can be
sent into App Engine
and stored within data store,
and all of the player profiles
that can be built up there,
by relying on the data
store and that
scalable technology.
And you'll notice
that everything's
going through this
Cloud Endpoints.
And this is a
fantastic technology
that provides RESTful APIs,
strongly-typed libraries,
and authentication.
I had to do all of this before
Cloud Endpoints was available.
And you kids these days,
just have it so lucky.
And Cloud Endpoints abstracts
away a lot of the complexities
there.
But if you want to use your
own authentication RESTful API
system, feel free to sprinkle
that in there as well.
And the last aspect is the
virtual machine orchestration.
And that really is
scaling the cluster
up and down with respect
to demand and player load.
And there's actually
two things that
make that great
on Compute Engine.
One is we do minute billing.
So if you need to
spin up and burst
and then terminate
down instances,
you don't have to
worry about, oh, I'm
getting billed by the hour.
How does my logic take
into account that?
You can just
terminate an instance,
and you're only charged
for what you used there.
Similarly, the
consistent performance
that you're not going to have
keep an eye on your instances
and find the ones that
are underperforming
so you can go in and
terminate those out.
And so the final last aspect
of this architecture, I swear,
is the big data aspect of it.
I know that's a
really fuzzy term that
has a lot different
ways of looking at that
and slicing and dicing it.
And just one example here is you
have all the game server logs,
every single player action,
everything people are doing,
dumping that into a permanent
storage in cloud storage
is easy.
And it's really cheap to
keep it there long-term.
And then you can start to do
things like MapReduce jobs
over that to aggregate down
to player actions per day,
instead of every
single player action.
And from there, you can pipe
into tools like BigQuery
that can do ad hoc, real-time
analysis on billions
of rows of data.
And so there are
these tools that
allow you to get
really great insights.
And typically, what we
find is people start
building on the left, get
the core gameplay working.
And as they scale
and as they grow,
they start to sprinkle
in more features.
And eventually,
they're into BigQuery,
to actually understand
and get insight
into what's happening
with their applications.
And so one more reference
architecture for you
here-- and this is along the
mobile gaming one as well.
And this is your typical
mobile gaming application
with a complex back
end, where you're
supporting multiple
devices, you're
scalable to millions of
players, and you really
want to sprinkle in the
engaging social aspects.
And with that, we have an
awesome sample application--
which, if you want to just
throw something out there
in the app store, you
can download this, put it
in the App Store
or the Play Store,
and see if you can get any
revenue driving from it.
It's actually full-featured,
and pretty awesome
to add more riddles
to it, et cetera.
And so what this game is,
it's called "Griddler."
And essentially, it's kind
of a player versus player,
asynchronous game, where
you get a riddle such as,
what has to be broken
before it can be used?
And you highlight, oh, egg.
And so you highlight egg.
And you're competing
against your friend
to go through all of
these different riddles
and get a score at the end.
And so that asynchronous
game works really well
on App Engine.
We see a lot of people
being very successful
with that architecture
and game type.
And now you have a
great starting point
available on both Android
and iOS to move quickly there
and have a base implementation
to start building on.
And what does that look like?
Well, similar to what you saw
for "Song Pop," except we've
added a little bit more
in here with respect
to other components
that can drive value.
And so we have our
iOS, Android devices,
through Cloud Endpoints
to App Engine.
And one of the interesting
things we'll actually point out
here is the task queues
and scheduled tasks
and App Engine back ends.
If you've used iOS Push
notifications, for example,
you know they like you to
maintain sockets and not
just open and close
a million sockets.
So what you can do
is have a back end--
a few back ends on App
Engine running continuously.
And what they do is
a pull/push request
from the task cube,
batch those together,
and then push those over
Apple push notification,
just so you can tap into
what Apple expects you
to do with respect to
push notifications,
and harness the
scalable components
within App Engine and the
task queues, et cetera.
And that's just one of the ways.
And we actually have
a sample for that
as well, if you're
interested in doing that.
And the other aspect here
that's worth calling out
is cloud storage, once again.
And you don't have to choose
between App Engine or Compute
Engine.
It's really about
picking the best
tool for what you're doing.
And so say you have an
application where people upload
pictures and video, and you want
to do some transcoding or image
manipulation on that.
You can upload that
through App Engine,
dump that into cloud storage.
And then using task
queues, you can actually
orchestrate the
processing of those videos
with Compute Engine,
whatever custom software
you want to run
on that, and then
put it back in cloud storage
and send notifications back.
There's lots of
flexibility here,
and a million different ways
to combine these components
and really pick what works
best for your use case
and application.
And so just to quickly wrap
it up here, what we've seen
is really-- sorry for the
cropping at the very top,
not quite sure what
happened there.
But we've seen Google is the
best place for developers.
From AAA to indie
studios, we love
seeing what people are
building on the platform.
If you have anything great
or you're thinking about it,
please talk to us.
We'd love to hear from you.
You'll see there's
a couple of Google
employees in the audience.
And they may be heads
down on laptops.
Apologies for that--
it's performance review
season at Google, and
everyone's a little bit
stressed out about that.
But we're more than
happy to talk to you
and put our laptops away.
And with that as
well, we have papers
talking about the
reference architectures.
And we also have those
sample applications.
If you just Google any
words that come to your mind
from this session, you'll
probably find them.
Otherwise,
cloud.google.com, the papers
are all there to
go in and look at.
Otherwise, our GitHub account
has the samples on it.
And this link here is to
a prettier GitHub version
that has a little
bit more readable.
But you'll also find everything
on the cloud GitHub account.
I guess I'll leave
that up for one more
minute, given the pictures here.
But if you just search for
whatever's on your mind,
you'll find it.
I've done it a million times.
And so lastly, this
one you'll actually
really want to
take a picture of.
And this is a really cool deal.
It is $2,000 in Cloud Credits.
Basically, go to--
wow, that QR code
became giant on that screen.
That's taller than I am.
But go there, enter in the
form, enter in a project ID.
And you'll get $1,000
of App Engine credits,
which will take you
quite a long ways,
and also $1,000 in
Compute Engine, which
you can go very far on,
especially if you turn down
your instance and take
advantage of minute billing.
I've seen people build
some amazing systems
and run a quick test, OK,
tear down the instances,
change things for now.
And then run another quick
test, tear down the instances.
Great options there
for maximizing
the use case of these credits.
And that's basically it.
I realize there's no
Q&A, but thank you.
And I'll be around if you
have any more questions.